anyway joining us now live on the ground
uh in Jerusalem is Trace Gallagher
trace and Sean this is a very scary
night for Israel because as you note the
300,000 plus IDF soldiers on the border
of Gaza ready to go in some have already
gone in just think about that but three
weeks ago these people were mostly
bankers and accountants and plumbers and
now they are Fighters prepping to go to
war and it's unclear exactly how much
training or retraining they've got the
expanded ground oper ation Sean was
really meant to be at this stage
prepping the battlefield meaning you
send in your heavy tanks you send in
your big equipment to go in there and
kind of lay a path for more soldiers to
get in and in doing that you had IDF Air
Force uh teams going in all week
bombarding Northern Gaza so they too
could kind of lay that territory flat
make it easier to get a pathway in uh we
expected this to be exactly that
prepping the battlefield and yet The
Times of Israel is now reporting tonight
that there have been significant clashes
between Hamas and Israeli Defense Forces
we do not know the extent of those
clashes or if there are any casualties
and we don't even know if they're still
going on at this hour daylight about an
hour maybe two hours away here Sean we
expect these incursions each night to
get bigger as the ground war kind of
Moves In bigger and bigger and then move
their way from northern Gaza into
Southern Gaza or into Central Gaza the
question becomes what is the impact of
the ground war like Steve herrian was
talking about do uh do these the
incursions force Hezbollah in the North
in Lebanon to fire into Northern Israel
and how does it affect the negotiations
with the hostages we talked to a lot of
families who were hoping that they would
hold off on this ground war for maybe a
few more days or a few more weeks to get
give diplomacy a time to get their loved
ones out there was a lot of talk today
about cter that was negotiating some
hostage deal to get a significant number
of hostages out but as soon as this
expanded ground operation became
noteworthy that all stopped and so here
we are tonight A lot of people concerned
Sean that that this might slow down the
hostage negotiation and yet you have a
top Aid to prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu saying they believe the best
way to get these hostages out is to go
in and smash Hamas and take these people
out themselves Sean all right Trace G
we'll have more on that throughout the
evening stand by Trace also will be on
uh right after us tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else